never actually hung out with me in
person
who's not yeah come on I'm wired not a
fan of what not not a good story the
characters [ __ ] in the story was wait
what are you talking about Elina battle
angel
oh [ __ ] out of here you didn't like it
either
hey beat you come back man come back bro
you can't I don't think Wesley so push
that [ __ ] things talk about gaming
nothing out of context
so it was just it was it was
disappointing to me like I was literally
like the action in the visuals room you
got to get back into that then there
he's hurt bad you right okay well thank
you I don't know man I don't know what
[ __ ] yeah plane was not gonna check okay
how do I come on YouTube and I'm looking
on my iPad oh there we go
live chat yeah so you make money
[ __ ] stupid ad as you're
collecting $20 from people how do I
sound chat before we get started what
graphing with graphic
the gang's all here I'm trying to get my
second win on Griffin gunner you see I
got some good ones I'm ready
battle what's up everybody listen man I
thought it was very you know it was I
don't know it was it was nicely put
together you know no no here we go here
here's something that I like if we will
talk about some [ __ ]
here's something that I thought was
ridiculous this ship this ship is
sitting in this water for a hundred
three hundred years and nobody found
that little thing I get the [ __ ] out of
here
you don't mean like it wasn't even lucky
was well hidden
it wasn't even well hidden you know the
reef I thought that was so stupid that
was a good point what about the fact
that like he dies she resurrects him and
then he dies like two minutes later like
what was the point of that that was the
dumbest [ __ ] ever
pointless done yeah I like oh that guy
had to die cuz he had done some bad [ __ ]
you know I mean yeah but I'm saying I
was I was fine with him dying I was fine
with him dying she was a creepy ass
robot though right take my heart you
know take my heart take my we'll just
get a cheap heart will you take this one
and we'll get it
I'm ready guys what's going on I'm ready
to start yeah we're in a game right now
play what probably died like two times
I'm just playing oh oh you act like when
you're with us you're not dying to
Oh Pikachu is feeling himself man he is
feeling himself it oh it does where the
[ __ ] you got to saying that cuz that
annoys me more than anything else it is
I don't know where's my friend
oh my god yeah you out your mind Wagoner
you mean what are you in a rut does Lee
brothers episodes gonna be 9:00 a.m.
Pacific Time is coming out I'm telling
you it's a good one it's a good one
yeah I want to see it I'm gonna watch it
yes it going Stevie I heard loses his
[ __ ] Steve was just hilarious man
yes he had me and Bobby mad at him I
can't wait I can't wait I was starting
up a taxi good everything yeah he's
playing [ __ ]
[Music]
okay let's go honey you're not playing
with him I'm jumping in I'm starting the
game I was playing Raqqa hide so Tuesday
we should hopefully have the thing done
well you get a bond now severance oh do
you what do you get no I'm getting on my
name is Craig hmm I heard your mom's
been working out art there how's she
looking she's down to just fat she was a
big [ __ ] together just fat I'm evil
this chat is you do I'm so here I'm so
tired of Oh Stu fat guy from Stevie we
me shut the [ __ ] up chat chat pieces
[ __ ] what what lovely the purple one doc
well yeah I wanted didn't I took a lift
ride tonight it was 70 cents
some deal today 70 set 70 cents I was
like this is great I gave the guy a
$2.00 are you doing oh you give him a
t-table son of a [ __ ] yeah that's it
enough that was back over there no I
look like what Batman smells like when
he retires alright let's do this
it'll be fun girl hey guys choices
I'm just take purple what hi let's do
this Gretchen we don't need those guys
it's hopeless
this guy's got 395 kill hey what's up
Izzy your liking yeah me and Griffin
will be playing it was it's like you
know what though I've been playing like
if there's no missions to do win it's
got that destiny boring factor I'm just
gonna let you know there's no pvp [ __ ]
that game and
well they'll get Duncan this guy's
taking us down
what up chat oh [ __ ] there's already
people shooting goddamn dude hey there's
a mirage [ __ ] there's a dude abalone
dude I gotta get out of here oh man I
went into the right building I got a
bunch of oh [ __ ] yes got a blue thing
got a blue knockdown shield I wanna get
right now oh I see a guy oh [ __ ]
guy up here oh this is what this is our
other guy I'm with our very nice but
there's a oh man you dis a guy up there
where you are correct I know I'm trying
to run away - OH
chat thank you you careful there's a guy
thank you I'm coming to you as donations
you coming over here let's go this other
building over here then we'll take this
zipline already oh we're in the circle
in there there's nothing where I checked
it yeah that was another guy in there
that's where I started man that sucks
nothing yeah we can save you coming in
here did you like the all-star
those that was craziness I don't know
what I was doing right there yeah
okay I need to heal oh my god
oh wait did you guys see that that was
insane oh this guy's got a heal thing is
that you crank or this guy that's me
I need some fun you got ammo bad we got
to go we're already in the circle I know
but we gotta go somewhere else oh yeah
what is he doing we gotta go let's go
let's go
it's got stupid let's go through this
cave see there's a [ __ ] here oh my God
he's sort of following that oh this [ __ ]
over here let's get this stuff man I'm
ran up on that one III know how you take
that case you know you do you run in
there and just [ __ ] die
you're just [ __ ] there we go
everybody I got something for this I got
so sore winner I got a sore winner yeah
some sore winner
I saw champions win sorely let's see we
got over here
oh the ships begin on the ship I'm going
on care for it Pikachu roll with hey got
you oh my god
oh I forgot to put I got a Mickey I got
to put baby arms up to my gosh ships
golden dude dude just a bunch of [ __ ]
right here just like like five cases
down here oh yes wait wait
I want this shotgun Oh give me just
ninja star mean Josh start wait how do
you get on the ship we're still here
just watch this jump y'all gotta get up
there oh [ __ ] I didn't do it right man
take some heavy rounds in the circle in
the [ __ ] too though yeah that guy took
that gun he's not taking all this
[ __ ] ammo though I'll tell you that
do I have one of these god damn this
guy's a thief man all right six seconds
oh we're in the circle we should stay up
here do you have a devotion with Craig
in this game yeah I got some kills I
gotta kill the guy got one kill for over
a thousand damage there's a care package
coming down on ethnic legends what are
we doing are we stay in there back to
the chat
I don't know we could I mean if somebody
comes up I know we could blast him
there's only one way to come up they got
to come up to zip line so you know we
can yeah but there's there's okay so
then we should like oh well we can't
talk to this guy what would she leave
then maybe my man actually launched my
thing on top of [ __ ] I can launch our
thing here I can get this what I'm
looking at to see everybody I catch you
launch the subject course is that 10
there's ten squads left come on be my
second were not somebody's like screw
the leaves they have been worse our
change that's me that's me let's write
it so let's wait till I'm looking at the
ropes here oh I see him I see him
oh my god can't reach down there I'm
wasting ammo down there's a mirage
yeah he's hiding behind that wall right
where's the this window right here oh
that guy killed that guy dude wait 10
damaged oh my god somebody's mission
Frank immature Frank who [ __ ] is that
right let's go let's go oh he was just
when you just all take let's go not the
ship wait which way Circle
oh I see okay I got you
I don't think this has been that's right
I didn't say that I said I was down yeah
we'll check the court minutes we'll
check the court minutes later and then
it can damage ten [ __ ] damage I just
saw know what no one's hit this stuff
look there's a thing over here man oh
good I need this ammo
oh [ __ ] give me all this ammo give me
this term acronym all right let's go
wait I'm going in wrong direction we
gotta go this way the map sucks oh you
were this way yeah yeah we gotta go this
way oh I see some more of these crates
man there's so many crates right here
we're gonna do this touch stream how
come and be careful if Craig and I get a
win it'll just be like I gotta get a win
without you mean exactly we have it on
tape tape me get that victorious [ __ ]
what is that oh that's my I dropped that
that's my ship [ __ ] no dude [ __ ] I
told you buddy everybody everybody got
[ __ ] let's go
needs a recharge mister let's go oh
there's more [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh good the
circle is collapsing and have a
select-fire for a problem I know I know
we're good we got time what not to my
shields that do you make any sense
[Music]
behind us we gotta go we gotta go let's
go come on we gotta go now go behind us
oh it's not okay this let's go
oh [ __ ] I'm on the wrong [ __ ]
direction
yeah Paul me call me call me almost ran
into the circle guards over here Greg we
gotta go this way oh [ __ ] yeah we gotta
go down here no go down here go down
there alright just a guy I don't know
where'd you guys go
we're right here man one that outskirts
get over here you guys went that way
alright I'm coming yeah because the
[ __ ] circle with this guy I like what
just guys do it alright oh [ __ ]
what Oh oh my god Wow awesome I say
holster your weapons just just too many
generals in my chat right now you know I
mean I'm talking on my house do this do
that
I want that okay I see where we're at
we're coming right now yeah let's take
this be golden clutch with the revive oh
you're above me you're above me
no no but just
building right here I'm like hope you
get hold all [ __ ] just probably somebody
over here let's let's go with this how
the [ __ ] you get see you guys are up
there though I can't get up there I
don't think oh man this all I gotta go
that I am coming to you that with this
guy better be careful yeah I see doors
and [ __ ] right now
I'm coming I'm coming I'm right here Oh
somebody had like a look look somebody
had a thing here optimum yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] I bet you they're in this they're
down here man now they might have left
they might have left dude I was just
down there
on the left side nobody was there if
they're anywhere they're in this
building to our left
oh man this is a disaster just hold this
all right let's take this building dude
which building let's hold this here the
one I'm in the one we came out of right
here picture let me know when you get
another one of those I hear some fire oh
we're in it oh we're moving in it inside
this this isn't this is crazy
I'm here for you yeah four squads left
and it's hard I got a hard one I don't
think it's daniel cormier chat to chat
you know what the thing is gonna they're
gonna come from this room right here man
from this door cuz like to death there's
no there's gonna be in this room there's
nobody there's nobody in fact no you
can't get back I had to go through
Solomon get there they're not coming
that way they're coming out the front
okay the circles here right in front of
us yes I'm seeing so let's just hold
this - yeah yeah yeah yeah
no it's gonna be right outside means to
me let's wait till closer I'm running to
you guys I think it's gonna be in this
room man like it's gonna cut half
there's a slight fire holy two squads
let's see how close it gets it's coming
see that we gotta go outside no Griffin
yeah I need some healing yes three
squads left three squads left they got
to be coming from here right they're
gonna be in front of us so let's just
yeah watch that side let me know well
give me what we can get close Pikachu
[ __ ] hi gorgeous so what's the deal is
it honestly I was reading shad I'm sorry
I won't happen again they're gonna be
straight ahead of us I'm sorry chat
don't goes I don't matter right now
they're taking that building oh we have
to go this way huh oh [ __ ]
yeah we got a good almost shot Craig did
you guys see that all in okay let's wait
though we should wait a minute I'm gonna
I'm gonna try to get behind this
building so we got cut hard here's cook
here's Craig Craig everybody no no this
is good this is good hold here hold here
I'm so close now we could see him
they're gonna be across let's go this
way
oh my god this is this is danger zone
right now
so Griffin be careful cuz we're over
here at this building oh my god yeah
we're at this building just
you know I'm trying to get over there
45m Cummings not too far this way this
way this way behind behind it's perfect
behind it are stay inside of it [ __ ]
okay I'm inside they gotta come indoors
to get see where they're at they're
gonna be it I don't see them yet they
gotta be out there to our right and
there's three squad left so that's a
tote that could be so there's six people
at least minimum maximum of six people
left maximum of nine including maps
right let's let him shoot oh yeah I know
the maximum of six but let it let us let
them come to us all right
like I don't I want to see if they get
getting a fight with each other I'm
gonna watch our back yeah let's let the
ring come all the way though oh this guy
left here with us get ready we're just
watching our back squad all right okay
no good but you're for a gun okay
they're not behind us certain both
they're not behind us I'm gonna go up
this car right if you didn't land in the
same [ __ ] spot oh [ __ ] okay I'm
coming
oh my god this is danger zone
go behind the car step I'm going I'm
going with this guy yes yeah put a house
thing over here oh this is it
we're gonna fall there in this building
they gotta be oh my god dude yeah let it
out let them find each other let them
find each other find each other they're
gonna find us no no no there's two teams
left let them find them dude I kept
coming around this way to you guys okay
all right we got we got a minute 30 oh
my god is I'm just anxious I'm gonna
throw a grenade up there no no don't do
anything don't do anything we don't know
where anybody is
don't do anything that might alert them
what I need
I'm gonna need some help no I don't
wanna find something
yeah oh my god this is like crazy
one more minute dude they got to be in
this building
oh why here yeah yeah okay let's go
let's go XL right [ __ ]
are you ready for this
are we in the circle we're in the circle
okay this is it we okay we got to hold
this room Craig get in here piece of
[ __ ] I'm here don't let him talk to you
like that Craig I'm just kidding Pikachu
oh my god three squads left continue
try it from miles away and he's got a
hold right now see this is the room we
release to you we're in the room that
they have to come to this is it this is
it y'all
oh my god oh my god okay I gotta go I
gotta go shotgun
I hear him I hear him they're outside
the building you can come wait on I put
my [ __ ] wingman down what the [ __ ]
[Music]
the window someone probably took my
wingman this guys coming in this
building right here coming around my
right there thank you yeah Coke's head
kick on Rivera's nasty
No
damnit well I got that 216 damage though
216 no kills those 140 under 44 that was
a choke job
I was terrible pick it up are you guys
one of you guys still playing we want
you to get with us yeah well if you want
to play if you guys want to let cope
jump in somebody wants to jump with me I
mean Griffin jumping somebody wants to
jump with me well let's just go cuz
they're still playing again we'll secure
this compound right here you can drop it
here okay I'm coming I'm coming
Wesley's I'm away from us I've got no no
I'm coming up oh yeah I gotta go take a
piss
yeah bro yeah bro
yeah I'm sitting blood-soaked
accelerants here okay oh man there's
yeah yeah whatever yo crunch we got
killed what do you want I'm gonna call
it
we should have pushed I know but we were
you know Liam a third I don't know how
to plays yeah I know I'll be shoot well
the guy was good you know he we lasted
he got a kill he's our only kill on the
team that's true I should add that first
guy let the door blocked me yeah we
should have had that guy went around and
they they were I was going around and
they were coming around so they had the
same idea but it was two on one I think
he baited us I think he fainted us that
was the thing he was trying to beat the
guy and then they were coming around
it's all good I try to get out there
anyway mega chat hey Chad I know we can
that's what we do he just can press B
and you can release there we go
what's up this captain we've got a lock
well I'm trying to see all right there
resin can you do that thing more shells
with the second circle yeah not yet all
right all right Stan what's this guy
doing no is he gonna jump
I have no idea there's one he's going to
some spot let's see what happen this
separated
this is apex legend
I know news go see we're that they're
going to the drop so that's why you win
no they don't also on Twitter I'm not
looking at the twitch chat so sorry
twitch chat sorry Chad I'm staying with
this guy
stay frosty stay frosty
next rings far oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
somebody's already shooting oh my god
yeah guy you shoot someone he plugs the
mob I totally took that guys
balcony up top right now well there's
just so much [ __ ] up here the [ __ ]
gun
Ida took that all the way over there we
can lose these bodies I don't think
anybody's here right yeah I think I got
a synchronization oh my god
I'm outside I had to run down this guy's
chasing me where are you I'm outside I'm
running around cuz they're shooting me
dude I don't see where you are I can't
even see you oh there you are there you
are I'm I'm coming I'm tugging dude I'm
trying to get this dude because they're
gonna [ __ ] film
over here oh it was Oh God terrible dude
I needed a gun
[ __ ] Mozambique Oh [ __ ] gun
doesn't do [ __ ] damn it why don't they
just get rid of that gun the Mozambique
it's okay yeah it's the worst [ __ ]
gone dude
I mean it was like right that's the guy
shooting him and not sorry one more for
me because I have to like I got an
audition in the morning guys we audition
for some like new CBS show Star Trek no
it's called something I don't know
say it's top secret guys I'm trying I
wanted to be an alien in Star Trek
that'd be dope
there's only they really left audio
delay in seconds what should it be
- sorry I don't know how to set it up
the why fix it Arthur don't piss me off
I really gotta go pee really bad I don't
want to disappoint coke which I'm
probably gonna do an you know piss right
now don't piss right now don't piss
right now no piss right now go piss
right now go do it if you seconds
there's one of the squad left one of
this one look yeah yeah you gotta wait
you know what I think I did it I think
that's it
I think I fixed a delay y'all I'm gonna
go find out where the next circle is I'm
the following Cove did I do it I got to
go pee bad but for the stream I gotta
help Pete
all right guys Chad told me of that big
stack of likes me
alright we're right in it dude they have
a reason oh yeah I got it I'm up to
eight kills he didn't know our original
Star Trek the approachin it froze it up
look let me see you could jump master
give me your energy stream I gotta go
pee go piss it's a long drop done by now
oh it's Jersey looks good my trip was
perfect for me
oh okay
secret bunker let's grab this [ __ ] and
take the box let's go oh [ __ ] here's
like a here's these things right here
give me a gun baby give me a gun yes yes
yes yes they were inside grip and we're
going in the bunker it might be longer -
I'm walking I'm walking the whole site
going up here oh my god oh my god
just give me another time man I need
guns dog heavy rounds nobody wants this
[ __ ] wait where are you going oh you
guys are way over there and I gotta
launch your [ __ ] right here but I don't
got any good guns attention no but
that's alright we gotta get comes the
first blood fire baby it's not there do
you want a hand watering in the [ __ ]
circle this is great oh hey here you
want that you want this all right I'll
take this is crazy to have two squads
left with these big circles - dad yeah I
don't see I don't I'd hear Pikachu
alright real quick yes like a hearing
about it don't shoot don't shoot don't
shoot
it's a [ __ ] wait I lost sight of him
but he's oh my god I think he might be
by himself
well I say no yeah no no he's got the
partner he got a partner over there
oh my god are you guys carrying Arthur
again oh god okay so I thought it looks
like two people so far wait okay I'm in
the [ __ ] alright engine might be focused
towards us we got height oh yeah we do
[Music]
[ __ ] I had this you know what I better
just take this guy champion mater what's
going down
zipline blending okay I'm back what
happened if you want me there
[ __ ] going for that get back
whatever whatever whatever
I'm going now I got so much ammo on this
and we gotta get downstairs one two
hours but under days at us you ready
I need help although you are come on
dude that [ __ ] shotgun dude or
getting team shot one but not with a
blood hunting rape alright Griffin I'm
coming to you I don't know what this
third guys doing we got everything over
there turned up my shield we did this
here Danny tell [ __ ] these are a when
aren't their wins
thank you stream for giving me the
energy to go pee fast oh my god I can't
or the can this guy is just too much
dude again here my pika TV goddammit we
actually take one of these guns huh
semi-auto sniper so it automatically
takes your the ammo from your other is
that right wait hey coke good [ __ ] on
the damage bonus we can all be hit on
the cake guys if you need some oh my god
this is what you guys should come to me
I'm in the circle I'm I got this
building locked out no okay well there's
like a thing right here that you okay
coke just like three cases right here
finally I got the most kills I'm skating
without coke thanks the coke and Wesley
oh yeah real real humble cuz my back
doing my back steam pretty good no I'm
just kidding oh my god
there we go Pikachu Pikachu plays a
hundred bad games has one game where he
does all right now he's [ __ ] king [ __ ]
yeah he'll yeah it's convenient how he's
reading to chat
I feel like Griffon now it's [ __ ]
money right behind right behind there's
a drop headed boy right there I jump
down jump down over there on the other
side of the building here this way this
way this way right here where's our guy
going I'll hear this okay
care package over half that's right we
just won a game Oh God
such [ __ ] I know carry them yeah
yeah really the chests just asking you
shut up author you know I mean all this
all that's on the chat you just leave
searches for the one that's like it says
like Oh pick a TV that one we gotta go
well yeah we're in the circle I have no
idea now I was following him cuz I don't
trust you but here we go [ __ ] he's doing
like he's still over there now
I do we got it like we should be in the
circle like I don't know what that guy's
how are you guys on guns
weight-wise dude how did he get hard to
get in front of me what the [ __ ] right
is here right
am i playing with the real Wesley Pipes
Leslie oh you see that I got a lot of
Miss okay I'm not the [ __ ] porn star
right I fell they say I'm not the [ __ ]
importantly who's Wesley Pipes the porn
star why not yeah I spoke you should
just own it
well first of all why do you know male
porn star names you're a game porn star
dude that's where your gay porn nice
laying down the pipe literally music is
a game for star not a game game again
what is this K I'm surprised there isn't
a genre for that like you know you're
like while you're playing games you know
yeah you get your buddy eating while
you're pouring ass eating motivation
[ __ ] damn it oh my god
the worst team shooting stars what are
you talking about
ninja stars he missed with 20 ninja star
that guy was [ __ ]
that teammates you guys want to game
with us well Griffin if you want to do
one game winners somebody said it's my
first time watching and they're just as
bad as I thought they'd be
we don't dissing we don't disappoint
[ __ ] we don't disappoint yeah
carry you Oh terrible hey Shawn come on
Shawn we need to help dude there we go
Oh doctors points are name be baby arms
Wesley for Coke I have I can
well I have the choke and everything for
the Peacekeeper if you want to take it I
have all the attachments in that anybody
[ __ ] that I'll do that brother would you
oh my god
alright last game our new burn so crazy
how coke always carries Arthur and you
never carriers I care that much so
no no Bilbo Baggins you're a hater and
you see the [ __ ] okay so guys come
aboard are you
I got hit with this luggage I can't
[ __ ] move more than that
okay let's take swamps with sick swamps
ethnic legends be aggressive desert is
there any way to strike back again it
was I've worked I've been down
teleporter at them I'm gonna go to the
back I'm gonna go the back over here
I've even tried you declining into play
because I mean I want to I want to get
you know enough stuff in front
toward them
cheerleader eliminated perfect me no not
perfect what colors
yeah okay want to take that gun
I mean come on longbow what's up what's
up let me know what you guys are running
so I can find attachments uh I got a
switch I want to find a better happy
happy I got a blue armor here blue armor
for that somebody needs it marker go
talk to your people I am talking to my
people blue armor welcome to ethnic
legends brother brother brother
yes I'm older than 18 I'm 12 oh hi oh
there's a triple tap here
I don't want it I'm gonna be you guys
wanna tap damn it should have that one
there get your scopes yeah backpack here
okay come on by your internet slow no
down Arthur wouldn't Leslie here I don't
think it's your titties what I want that
no stop saying stuff are you gonna
deport eighty Reaper kiddies no we talk
disturb pika sounds like he's in his 20s
that's me dawg
twins aren't you like 37 yeah pretty
much
right sorry I'm not oh he's close not
there yet he's got the head of a 37 year
old body shrug down he's the doctor or
whatever he's got that shrunken head
yeah his head looks like the head of a
37 year old but it's the size of a four
year old the champion fell very careful
I feel like these doors have been open
and I don't know guys following you
think you're here to be my backup but
you know you have never seen our screen
wait I think there's somebody on the
left I thought I saw some right bumper
maybe I have to get respond in order to
[ __ ] champion
oh [ __ ] so hostile that means is a
hostile yeah yes that's correct
okay anything on the balcony
okay you guys sore winner Koch Craig
Griffin t-shirt mad at Pico while each
of you are holding a trophy okay yeah
we're working on it we're gonna get
shirts back oh [ __ ] we gotta get to the
ring right yeah
yeah we're good we're good yeah time
safe say hurry put it in the Asian
accent all right I don't know I can't
believe you just what's up what's up
don't even do that you please dropped
over at that damn yeah so let me let me
die and then I don't know who's I can't
tell who's who right now I know it's
like the white guy here the white guy
passes are blending together let's go
you get it
the Rings moving yeah heads up the Rings
oh [ __ ] the Rings movie come with us I'm
coming
and let's um let's try to camp up here
and make sure why to make sure the ring
closed you how much they're gonna be in
this bunker let's go in the bunker and
try to you just want to you want to see
sure them a blown-up image of Craig's
face don't we could do that we have to
be next to large hey no he's not
oh he did okay they might be up here
outside so let's be careful because they
don't know I'm that much faster me
let's come over here I'm gonna drive up
here I'm gonna take this this Ridgeline
ones down and one that's not mine here's
something yeah come up here with us what
if we're in the same game is them scopes
a cheater no wanna kill copes ass
alright let's see let's see we're circle
never remember when we landed in the
same game and we just [ __ ] white all
right [ __ ] let's let's wait till ring
lets with or winner man that wasn't a
beta-blocker before he does his audition
okay dripping tape Baylor Parker
hopefully you're not hopefully you're
not bugged again Wesley yeah I felt we
could have won that game not this great
huh what's that I'm just waiting to
other [ __ ] dude we don't care about your
giveaway dawg
yeah thank you a lot 10th 10 euros for a
past safeguard oh yeah that should we
don't even need euros we're in America
yeah this is America this guy said the
podcast premiere time is not good for
Europe you'll be able to watch it after
that you know what I mean mm-hmm
what does a guy down below somebody
right yeah yeah but just just talk don't
make don't don't tip them off yet I want
to wait till we see where the ring moves
okay oh [ __ ] we're favorite person is
Steve ready look Dan Griffin
oh we're knee-deep in the ring let's
just stay yeah let's just control let's
just control this here I'm gonna drag is
my favorite chess player
it's kind of funny I'm dropping that
there behind us but Oh Craigs now now
everybody's gonna be all Craig's then we
have to do a we have to do like a
t-shirt of Craig as a chess player now
and I don't want it
my buddy kick he's been like training oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm gonna do [ __ ] let's go
let's go watch out
I can't revive you let's just just cover
each other I'll drop down bye-bye you
you coming or no keep coming I am oh my
god have no he's right above the dress
oh this guy dropped down on me I can't
believe it I was trying to use the
portal okay alright well I didn't get my
second win
no second one guys alright what's ready
up you out gravity play another I'm out
I'm out I gotta go yeah guys everybody
that's watching right now if you want to
go over watch baby arms you know if you
want to go watch the four-year-old head
I'm gonna go over to worst fire team
ever potus's switch over to worst fire
team guys I know a lot of you are
watching right now I've got a hundred
fifty people in here so I think you
should go swing over the worst fire team
because we're gonna start streaming over
there more than here but thanks a lot
for paying attention and the Bobby Lee
and Steve Lee movie review episode airs
and amorepacific time 9 and 12 Eastern
at 12:00 Eastern you guys are great
alright peace and thanks for watching
Griffin Dermott oh I didn't put it in
yet
hold up there it is Griffin go burn